حصيله هذه الهجمات الباكستانيه في سروان
وقالت ان تسعه قتلوا في هذه الهجمات هل
حمل خبر الوكاله اي تصريح رسمي بخصوص ما
جرى م بكل تاكيد الان الابحاث والتحقيقات
جاريه في عين المكان حيث تم الهجوم
الباكستاني وكما اسلفنا في وقت سابق بان
مساله الضحايا ومساله القتله ربما هي
مساله وقت للحديث عن ارتفاع العدد وعن حجم
الدمار الذي حدث بتلك المنطقه وهو ما حدث
بالفعل حينما يتم الحديث على ان عدد
القتلى بحسب المعاون السياسي لمحافظه
سستان وبلوشستان بانه وصل الى تسعه قتلى
بينهم رجلين وبالتالي هذه تعتبر اخر
احصائيه لكن مريم الاهم الان المطروح هو
ما بعد هذا الهجوم يبدو ان هناك تحركا
ويمكن ان نصفه هنا بطهران بالتحرك الهادئ
باتجاه باكستان لمعرفه ملا ملابسات ما حدث
وماذا اقدمت عليه باكستان باتجاه الاراضي
الايرانيه وذلك من خلال مجموعه من
التحركات الدبلوماسيه من خلال التصريح
الذي صدر عبر التلفزيون الايراني عن مصدر
مطلع الذي بكل تاكيد ادان هذا الحادث
وطالب باكستان بتقديم توضيحات بشان هذا
الحادث بل اكثر من ذلك حينما نتلمس ونلتمس
او نقرا بشكل واضح ما صدر في وسائل
الاعلام الايرانيه عن استدعاء ايران
للقائم بالاعمال الباكستاني هنا بالعاصمه
الايرانيه طهران نلمس بانه تصريح هاد نوعا
ما هو استدعاء لتقديم توضيح لم يكن بشكل
قوي وقاسي ربما قد يفهم منه ان طهران تريد
الذهاب ابعد او ربما لرفع وتيره التوتر مع
الجانب الباكستاني التصريح من الخارجيه
الايرانيه كان واضحا وسلسا في تعبيره
حينما قال بانها استدعت القائم الاعمال
لتقديم توضيح الى الجانب الايراني بكل
تاكيد هنا نلمس بان الجانب الايراني على
الاقل ربما لا يريد الذهاب بشكل كبير الى
تصعيد اكبر وقد نقرا هذا وكما اشرنا الى
ذلك في وقت سابق فيما يتم الحديث عنه عن
العمليه الايرانيه داخل الاراضي
الباكستانيه وكان التصريح واضح حينما تقول
طهران بانها استهدفت مقار للمجموعات
الارهابيه وكذلك التصريح الباكستاني لكن
يب السؤال دائما حينما يتم الحديث عن
عمليات عسكريه من هذا النوع عبر هجمات
صاروخيه او مسيرات او عبر الطائرات
المقاتله يبقى السؤال دائما اين كان
الجانب العسكري سواء الباكستاني حينما كان
الهجوم الايراني او الايراني حينما كان
الهجوم الباكستاني يبدو ان هناك حديث الان
بدا ينقل وربما قد نتلمس ذلك في تصريح
الخارجيه الباكستانيه حينما تقول بشكل
واضح اننا ابلغنا الجانب الايراني بهذه
المواقع هنا ربما قد ننقل الكلام الى
مستوى عسكري هل كان هناك تنسيق مسبق ما
بين الجانب الايراني والجانب الباكستاني
على هذا المستوى الامر قد يبدو غير مستبعد
بهذا الاتجاه باعتبار ان العلاقات
العسكريه الايرانيه الباكستانيه هي علاقات
عسكريه قويه ومتينه ويمكن الاشاره على انه
قبل يوم من هذه العمليه كانت هناك مناورات
مشتركه ما بين الجانب الايراني
والباكستاني على مستوى البحريه الايرانيه
والبحريه الباكستانيه في بحر عمان لهذا
ربما قد تبدو ان هناك ترجيحات وقراءات على
ان شيئا ما يدور على الجانبين العسكري
الايراني والباكستاني نوردين دغير من
طهران